what was it like um you
burden of truth is done right
did that upset you were you upset that
it got cancelled
no we wanted it to end there was no more
story to tell
really there's always a story to tell
isn't there
well there isn't that's what the fans
will say the fans will say that they'll
say there's always stories to tell
yeah yes i suppose that's true but um
the stories that we wanted to tell
were were kind of done it was a show
that hinged a lot on
uh cases that revealed personal it kind
of had a finite structure to it
and we didn't want to i mean we pushed
it one season extra more than we had
planned to um
and we were really happy with what we we
ended up with and and we felt like it
was it was time to
retire the characters so you knew it
ahead of time or were they did they say
hey we're not getting you so you knew
the season the last season was the last
season did everybody know or did you
just know because you're an executive
producer no no we all we all knew i mean
mostly it was weird because i thought
that the cbc would announce that and
they never and they never did so we were
always like can we talk about this can
we so we just it was like a weird it was
a weird situation that way but yeah i
think most of us knew it was the end
yeah and how do you how do you react now
you know at your age and the amount of
work you've done when it ends are you
sad are you you fulfilled are you like
do you you just kind of move on and go
what's next
i i think the i think the latter but i
it doesn't negate how meaningful the
experience was right especially on
burden of truth i it was such a
meaningful experience
and the people that i worked with and
the stories that we got to tell meant a
lot to me
so
it feels like that's that's meaningful
but when i leave a show it feels like
i'm
it feels like okay done
but it's always felt that way i don't
know maybe i think i'm weird that way
you're not a crier you're not a big
crier i i am i'm a crier but i i don't
know that i cry about
like
work that much what do you cry about